Ah ah ah davvero Lascia il computer
Aiuto aiuto
che bella tonta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho sentito un rumore strano può venire
da qua Hai sentito anche tu veniva
proprio da qui
Eh ma guarda
come è possibile che cosa sta succedendo
[Musica]
che si sono animati gli oggetti no
in casa un fantasma come un fantasma è
meglio se scappiamo ok
e beccati questo c'è qualcosa e anche
questo
non lo stiamo beccando vedi non c'è più
niente
Dove arriveranno
No no non ho mai preso niente invisibile
continua a mangiare così
aspettate pure questo non abbiamo preso
niente Non riusciamo a capire ah ah
Uffa la prossima volta che vedo un
cuscino volare lo prendo così Non c'è
più niente
dove sei fantastica
ma forse sono stato io che ho fatto così
l'avete visto
Sono qui sono qui Cos'è che stai facendo
Non ti fai colpire da solo mi hai
toccato l'ho sentito stava qua Vitale è
così confuso da colpirsi da solo
cosa sta succedendo lì ah ah ah ah ah ah
presto Prendilo colpisce la testa subito
Forse l'abbiamo beccato adesso guarda
sta scappando
Meno male se n'è andato Meno male così
abbiamo il tempo per elaborare un piano
e questo vuol dire che
abbiamo un fantasma in casa presto
prendiamo del peperoncino un po' di
insalata
no Ma cosa c'entra Non stiamo
collaborando un antidoto come gli
episodi precedenti A proposito li avete
visti se non li avete visti andate poi a
vedere il gatto mannaro ora dobbiamo
trovare un modo per far scappare il
fantasma da casa
lui si spaventa eh scappa non credo
Credo che una buona opzione potrebbe
essere travestirsi da fantasma e provare
a comunicare con lui lo spaventiamo così
grande Ottima idea cioè noi ci rivediamo
tra fantasmi Allora andiamo verso di lui
lo incontriamo facciamo boom e lui si
spaventa non credo che si spaventerà Ma
magari
riesci a capire perché
succede le cose strane qua in casa di
fiamma che cosa ci fa lui qua magari
Potrà darci una risposta e andarsene via
per sempre Va bene ma io credo che sia
lo spaventiamo meglio però Va bene dai
facciamo così cerchiamo di comunicare
o lenzuolo bianco abbiamo
Ecco Guarda cosa ho trovato questo è
perfetto per fare i fantasmi provare a
comunicare col fantasma prego mettiti
sotto guarda ho tagliato un buco poco
così riusciamo a vedere attraverso e
vedere dov'è il fantasma Anzi no non
riusciremo a vedere il fantasma perché è
invisibile ma non potevi prendere due
così uno lo tenevo solo io e potevo
scappare con più facilitaro e non volevo
tagliare un altro lenzuolo
vediamo poi vediamo
tarma dove sei vogliamo comunicare con
te eh Mica tanto vogliamo sapere che
cosa ci fai qua in casa di fiamme
soprattutto che cosa vuoi da noi e Anita
Ma sei sicura che questo questo lenzuolo
stia funzionando Non lo so se lui vuole
mettersi in contatto con noi Vedi In
effetti sembra sparito
signori siamo riusciti a spaventarlo
come dicevi tu eh Ti ho detto c'ho
sempre delle idee che funzionano che
sono fantastiche Io boh
fantasma
abbiamo fatto paura con questo vestito
credo proprio perché si sia spaventato
di noi non facciamo paura
[Applauso]
di noi non il fantasma Chi è stato dov'è
andato perché è troppo caldo
Visto che non riusciamo a vederlo
vediamo se riusciamo a sentirlo
[Musica]
non riesco a sentire niente eppure ci ha
spinto
ci credo mica ci ha detto
uh uh
è stato tu no non sono stato io pensavo
fossi stata tu per farmi uno scherzo il
fantasma
dobbiamo uscire fuori da questa stanza
allora
Ho un'idea proviamo a lanciare questo
lenzuolo così forse riusciamo a
catturarlo mi è venuto un'altra ancora
più bella Eh tieni questo lenzuolo e io
me ne vado Ciao Gabriele fantastico
[Musica]
in questa stanza Vogliamo solo
comunicare con te vogliamo capire perché
sei qua a casa di fiamme che cosa vuoi
da me
che cosa vuoi da noi ma perché perché
sei qua Esatto perché sei qua
[Musica]
le orecchie non ti sto toccando le
orecchie il fantasma allora che si sta
prendendo il gioco di me Beh visto che
il fantasma non ci risponde Forse è
meglio se andiamo via
non ti sentivo perché mi stavo coprendo
le orecchie così non mi tocca più le
orecchie il fantasma andiamo via Sì
andiamo via questa camera Forse se n'è
andato dici
[Musica]
Hai sentito veniva di là veniva proprio
di là Adesso lo prendo con questo basta
Mi ha stancato questo fantasma adesso ti
prendo fantasma
[Musica]
sento che si muove
Peccato
non lo vedo
[Musica]
vuole anche solo spaventarci
Qual è il tuo piano quindi sta cercando
di prenderlo
ma non ci riesco ormai abbiamo capito
che non riusciamo a prenderlo con
lei
ci sono due buchi
[Musica]
ragazzi
basta mi sono stancata degli scherzi di
questo fantasma
andiamo ok va bene andiamo però io ci
vorrei provare ancora una volta però
guarda
No è un fantasma amichevole mi conosce e
già sa che ho tanta fame
mi è arrivata Ho attaccato al dito ah ah
Andiamocene freddo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
presto presto che cosa facciamo adesso
dobbiamo trovare qualcuno che ci aiuti
contro i fantasmi
potremmo chiedere all'ex grande
l'ex è un mostrologo È vero me lo ripete
sempre perché dice che l'olio lo
dimentico lui è un mostrologo e studia
le creature Sì è il fantasma non è una
creatura No è un fantasma quindi
dobbiamo trovare qualcuno che se ne
intende di fantasmi sì qualcuno esperto
di fantasmi E dove lo possiamo trovare
Non lo so al supermercato
ho un'idea Creiamo un annuncio e
chiediamo aiuto online e chiediamo se se
c'è qualcuno esperto di fantasmi che può
aiutarci in ottima idea Dai facciamo una
storia Ciao ragazzi Abbiamo un problema
di
fantasmi
abbiamo bisogno di aiuto chiunque sia un
esperto di fantasmi per favore
contattateci perché è urgente il
fantasma è qua dentro casa e ci sta
facendo anche degli esperti Sì un sacco
di scherzi quindi
contattatemi se siete esperti di
fantasmi Ok grazie Ciao
Ok fatto
pubblicato online Speriamo che qualcuno
ci contatti nel frattempo che cosa
facciamo nel frattempo andiamo a
mangiare due pop corn nella testa
nel frattempo cercherò qualche
informazione sui fantasmi
tu Cerca il Diario di fiamma io cerco il
mio libro voi ce l'avete state paurose
Guarda mi ha risposto qualcuno Vediamo
vediamo il messaggio
da questa forse
Ah si è accesa la lucina beh
ma chi se non si vede bene in faccia non
riesco a capire che strana i capelli ho
visto il vostro annuncio Anita soli io
mi presento sono lo scienziato scpn
scpm Che nome strano
costruttore creatore faccio di tutto
sono qua solo per voi possiamo
incontrarci e trovare la soluzione
perché anch'io mi interesso di fantasmi
Verrò il prima possibile è trovare la
soluzione arrivo Anita Stories
forse abbiamo trovato la soluzione a
questo problema allora è un po' strano
però questo signore non so se possiamo
fidarci invitarlo a casa nostra e magari
gli Possiamo offrire Non lo so una
visita dal parrucchiere
i capelli così
lui è l'unica soluzione non abbiamo
scelta dobbiamo per forza invitare a
casa qualcuno che se ne intenda di
fantasmi Quindi io direi di rispondere e
dirgli che può venire a casa nostra e
aiutarci Che ne pensi contattiamolo ok
Eccomi Anita Stories sono arrivato
Eccolo è arrivato deve essere lui il
professor scpn
Ciao ciao
a fare la soluzione al problema del
fantasma Sì sì sì
sono perfettamente consapevole che
questo fantasma deve essere allontanato
Ok sì prego prego entra pure Entra pure
sono arrivato velocissimamente per
risolvere questo problema abitazione
solidale Grazie il problema del fantasma
Sì sì come potresti aiutarci e io potrei
atterrò
i prof Fammi vedere come trovare una
soluzione sì hai capito qualcosa Zero ok
Vabbè l'importante è che tu hai detto
che sei esperto di fantasmi vero Io sono
creatore io ho inventato tutto e
soprattutto sono pratico per
sparire i fantasmi sparire perfetto È
proprio quello che serve a noi il
fantasma che c'è in casa e quindi che
cosa dobbiamo fare Vi faccio vedere gli
oggetti che io ho portato gli oggetti
andiamo a comandare faccio vedere sono
gli oggetti fondamentali perché questo
fantasma finalmente sparisca Ok perfetto
ho capito Vediamo il primo Questo è un
orologio particolare questo orologio fa
sì che il tempo vada indietro È il
fantasma se il tempo va indietro si
confonde Chissà se funziona davvero
sembra fighissimo Il tempo va indietro
ma nel frattempo il tempo in realtà sta
andando avanti e schiacciano è fatta ma
mi sono confuso Anch'io Vabbè vediamo
che cos'altro c'è bene Questo è molto
delicato questo oggetto meraviglioso
Quando scrivi sparisce la scrittura e
fantasmi sono
praticamente impressionati perché loro
abituati a sparire e invece vedono la
scrittura sparizione rimangono un po'
strani e quindi è una matita magica
matitone Secondo me questo non c'entra
niente col fantasmi e poi
abbiamo Ecco Queste sono puntine le
puntine che possono essere lanciate al
fantasma e tutte le puntine si
appiccicano e fantasma ci confonde e non
riesce più a capire se lui è un fantasma
puntine Praticamente con le puntine il
fantasma diventa un cactus lo
Trasformiamo in un cactus sono un po'
strane questi oggetti di questo
professore fcpn però
Eccolo qua Ecco forse ha trovato
l'oggetto giusto è l'oggetto
meraviglioso che io ho inventato tanto
tempo fa questo oggetto cosa fa si sente
un suono il fantasma viene come
ipnotizzato
e quando ipnotizzato e rimane facile da
far sparire e come portando il tempo
all'indietro e portando il tempo
all'indietro poi io scrivo sul fantasma
perché lui è ipnotizzato e lui sparisce
Ok allora posso subito provare questo
credo con molta attenzione Vitale Sei
contento Un bacio gigante perché è un
buon contessimo Ok ma cosa devo fare
devo premere Qua sì appena delicata
delicata di testare Vitale Stai attento
perché sto lontano faccio un altro passo
indietro proviamo 3 2 1
[Applauso]
Ma che cos'è il clacson della nave
questo suono e viene da lontano viene
dall'essere astronomico che io ho
trovato durante una performance delle
montagne dell'Alaska ma veramente mi
sembra che questo sono arrivi da la
bocca di questo personaggio
E quindi cosa dobbiamo fare con questo
strumento con questo strumento
magico e meraviglioso basta suonare e
con la propria melodia dello strumento
possiamo far sparire il fantasma
Wow hai anche un ballerino
un bravissimo ballerino devo dire
Vabbè Eh signor scpn Allora innanzitutto
noi proveremo a comporre questa melodia
anche se è un po' difficile
ma prima vogliamo sapere un po' più di
informazioni su di te perché non
sappiamo se possiamo fidarci e tra
l'altro Che cosa vuol dire scpr
professor schiappenti il mio nome e il
professor schiappen
non ho capito ho capito Quindi
da lontano lei io vengo da lontano da
molto lontano io vengo da lontano
migliore
va bene professor schiappa e non d'ora
in poi la chiameremo così
Vabbè comunque grazie per questo oggetto
Allora noi proviamo a usarlo contro il
fantasma Proviamo subito potete usarlo
contro il fantasma però attenzione
all'intervicale perché
usandolo male si può fare la il
contrario che Voi potreste diventare dei
fantasmi
che noi diventiamo fantasmi e ce lo dici
solo adesso Appunto per quello vi volevo
avvisare bisogna utilizzarlo in maniera
molto delicata lo strumento magico lo
strumento meraviglioso
Quasi quasi potrei diventare un fantasma
per mangiare le cose di nascosto no
Eppure sembra uno strumento così carino
sembra che possa trasformarci Ma è
meglio stare attenti come dice questo
professore
Ho paura di fare danni Va bene lo userò
io Ok grazie mille Allora facciamo così
noi proviamo già a cercare il fantasma e
ad allontanarlo con questo strumento ma
tu se poi non andartelo che rimani qua
perché nel caso che succede qualcosa Non
vorrei che poi dobbiamo sbrigarci da
soli Eh sono già successe queste cose
quindi magari rimandi qua Ok puoi stare
pure in questa stanza
Certo va benissimo
Però ora come pagamento sì eh Non
avevamo discusso del pagamento quanto
costa non ha un costo di più di un costo
è uno strumento
meraviglioso che supera qualunque costo
che potete immaginare
o no E come faremo a permetterci questo
nuovo strumento Infatti come facciamo a
prepararlo allora basta che poi mi
pagate in questo modo mi date dei
dolcetti che la mia meravigliosa
debolezza e allora il problema è che a
casa Abbiamo solo dei biscotti non è che
abbiamo dei dolcetti vanno bene lo
stesso dei biscotti ioni a vedere la
forma del biscotto perché se la forma vi
piace è come il dolcetto e va bene
allora più o meno così un biscotto così
andiamo a prenderli e torniamo subito
così vediamo se possiamo pagare questo
strumento Va bene va bene Anita storie
Va bene Vitale potete andare Attenzione
attenzione
[Musica]
Finalmente sono andati via
posso mettermi comodo
Ecco i biscotti Secondo te andranno bene
non sono proprio dolcetti sono biscotti
andranno bene Ma sì guarda Quanto
zucchero c'è lui diceva dolcetti
dolcetti dolcetti con tutto questo
zucchero facevano sicuramente dolci no
ok portiamoglielo Ma secondo te perché
si chiama professor
schiappen Non lo so però fa molto ridere
penso di aver capito perché si chiama
ragazzi i dolcetti che meraviglia
che profumo che meraviglia bellissimi
Beh allora Vanno bene questi dolcetti
sono abbastanza benissimo Sono
meravigliosi Ci sono molti di Hulk che
splendido profumo bellissimo professore
a noi abbiamo un po' di fretta Però
perché il fantasma è pieno di sopra
dobbiamo debellarlo il prima possibile
possiamo quindi prendere questo questo
strumento Attenzione però delicato
Ricordatevi quello va bene allora noi
andiamo al piano di sopra e cerchiamo di
ipnotizzare far andare via il fantasma e
tu se vuoi rimanere resta pure qua a
mangiare pure i dolcetti ok Noi andiamo
ok va bene
che buona meravigliosa
l'ultima volta era qua il fantasma
abbiamo un'arma repellente contro di te
Sì Non potrei proprio farcela adesso e
tra l'altro questo lo strumento è
fantasmagorico Sì ma speriamo che
funzioni A proposito ma poi avete
lasciato un mi piace lasciate Mi piace
per aiutarci Anzi Provate a lasciare un
mi piace entro 5 secondi prima che
compaiono il fantasma cioè 5 4 3 2 1 0
il tempo scaduto sentite riusciti a
lasciare un mi piace ma non è comparso
il fantasma vero
fantasma
dove sei abbiamo un'arma contro di te
forse siamo già riusciti a farlo
scappare
[Musica]
ha funzionato già questa creazione di
schioppe sì che bello ma sarà scappato
dalla casa o solo da questa stanza
Infatti noi dobbiamo farlo andare via
dalla nostra casa cioè praticamente
dobbiamo andare a stanza per stanza fare
proprio proprio
Beh se funziona davvero
no qualcosa mi ha spostato i capelli
e qua in questa stanza non ha funzionato
forse devo suonare ancora un pochino
Ehi ma che serve questo Beccati questo
fantasma beccati questa melodia
bruttissima
[Musica]
Il problema è che non lo so suonare è
difficilissimo da suonare Guarda ho
preso il mio computer
Lascia che il computer ho detto
Lascia il computer
Ah ah ah non sappiamo il computer no no
basta l'ho detto lascialo Ah ciao
non sta funzionando sembra oggi che si
sia arrabbiato ancora di più il fantasma
mi ha tirato qualcosa in testa
proprio perché non funziona raga e
adesso dov'è ah ah ah ah ah ah
Ahia basta
Sì basta e c'è qualcosa che mi sta dando
fastidio forse quello Forse perché non
sto suonando bene lo melodia ma non
riesco a suonarlo cerca di questo
proviamo con una nota più alta
ah ah
questo suono
è fastidioso Guarda
è scappato non so come ho fatto ho
suonato una nota più alta ed è scappato
Bravo
adesso come facciamo dobbiamo andare a
seguirlo dobbiamo andare a cercarlo
dobbiamo dobbiamo cercarlo Sì magari un
dato dal professor schiappen No non
credo alla fine si ha appena detto che è
un esperto contro i fantasmi Quindi
anche se andasse da schiappen schiappa
caverebbe benissimo perché lui è un
esperto Ed è pieno di oggetti e quindi
sicuramente anche se il fantasma andasse
lì a schiappano non si perde Sì non gli
farebbe proprio un bel niente
dove vuoi aiutarlo è piatto con le mani
Qua accanto pianto No no no non andare
più avanti
[Musica]
Quindi adesso elaboriamo un piano per
trovare il fantasma e scacciarlo con
delle note giuste Però come hai fatto
prima Sì infatti proviamo
No no no è tornato basta Aspetta
troviamo prima la nota giusta prima di
andare a cercare il fantasma ok
[Applauso]
non era così non è neanche questa
aspetta era era un po' più alta
la sto facendo più alta No
dobbiamo tornare da schiappen e
chiederli Come facciamo a suonare questo
strumento con la nota più alta perché
altrimenti non ha funzionato sul
fantasma sono venuta più alta ha
funzionato Quindi
chiediamogli come fare
più le mangio e meglio
sono veramente profumati sono
profumatissimi Che meraviglia
Che meraviglia Ma sei una conta mille
spoglie a una torta margherita
[Musica]
Che meraviglia Che bella torta
però è buona è proprio buona
[Musica]
Berlino Non mangiarti la mia torta
Merlino Merlino lascia la mia storia
Merlino Spostati Spostati Merlino
[Musica]
la torta la torta buona però questa
torta Comunque era molto buona
meravigliosa ma tutto schiappen sembra
si sia esploso un bignè in faccia Sì è
vero non è proprio un bignè era una
torta torta margherita Eh vabbè al di là
di questa torta poteva Sì ci hai dato
questo strumento ci hai detto che
avrebbe funzionato contro il fantasma ma
non funziona anzi sei arrabbiato Sì sei
arrabbiato ancora di più il fantasma e
ci ha fatto di dispetti anche sì Quindi
hai detto che sei un esperto ma non
funziona questo strumento questo
strumento funziona benissimo è uno
strumento magico non ha mai sbagliato Ah
ecco le impostazioni sbagliate e per
quello che non funzionava Adesso ci sono
le impostazioni giuste e con gli
ultrasuoni i fantasmi spariranno
affetti da
Ecco perché prima ho suonato questa
notte alta Vi ricordate quando il
fantasma è sparito Ecco come ha fatto a
farlo sparire ci vogliono le note alte
per farli sparire Allora questa nuova
impostazione quindi sparirà
spariranno tutti i fantasmi e adesso li
andiamo a suonare tutte le note alte
così lo spaventeremo ma aspetta un
dubbio il fantasma sarà ancora al piano
di sopra Vediamo schiappa insieme magari
l'ha visto passare da qui hai visto il
fantasma per caso No non l'ho visto
niente io stavo semplicemente seguendo
la mia torta fluttuante
Vabbè ci pensiamo noi sì certo ci siamo
Ci pensiamo noi a cacciare il fantasma
proviamo a tornare al piano di sopra in
genere lì che si nasconde portiamo ora
il nostro strumento con le note giuste e
andiamo
Ciao sì
fantasma Dove sei questa volta abbiamo
l'impostazione giusta di questo strano
strumento e aspetta non suoniamo subito
lo strumento così lo vogliamo di
sorpresa
dove sarà però non c'è
Spero che non siate fare schiappa non è
che magari è andato da schiappender
Beh insomma è un po' strano quindi
magari non c'è vita
[Musica]
sta succedendo
Questa volta diluciuffo questa volta ti
piaccio
bravissimo un video
di merda
[Musica]
Ah Ah Ah guarda guarda guarda guarda
davvero
Sì sembra che gli dia fastidio
[Musica]
sta andando via
via
È laggiù Che cosa sono giù presto
andiamo a vedere
biscotti sono solo miei
deliziosissimo
ha funzionato il tuo strumento strambo
ve l'avevo detto io che avrebbe
funzionato grazie
Spero che potremo ricontattarti in
futuro se avremo altri problemi di
creatura il che succede spesso bene Sono
felice di avervi incontrato per
qualunque altra cosa contattatemi possa
aiutarvi anche con altri problemi che
avete con altre creature bene posso
anche
inventare per voi degli oggetti
fenomenali Wow Sarebbe molto
interessante Ci potrebbe tornare utile
per la nostra si è investigativa di
misteri Perché noi dobbiamo aprire
un'agenzia investigativa di misteri
ancora non abbiamo il nome ma comunque
la apriremo a breve e risolveremo
tantissimi misteri Ah interessante mi
farebbe piacere fa parte del team
onorato se questo avviene però una un
appuntamento in pasticceria Arrivederci
Anita Vitale Ora vado
grazie per l'aiuto Ci sentiamo a presto
bene Abbiamo sconfitto anche il fantasma
Cioè non proprio sconfitto se n'è andato
Grazie
credo che siamo pronti ad aprire la
nostra agenzia investigativa Ma se non
ci avete ancora consigliato il nome
scrivetecelo giù nei commenti e ora vi
lascio qua quattro cartellini su cui
cliccare per vedere le nostre altre
avventure cliccate su quella che
preferite eh Buona visione Ciao